when i started podcasting i just started
in my kitchen i didn't really know when
did you start i started maybe about five
years ago maybe or four years ago i'd
gone on joe rogan's podcast a couple of
times maybe i ca
it's a marathon that's not a podcast oh
dude it was so hard what do you guys how
does he have like does he have like a
like a notebook of stuff oh he just he
just goes he's a notebook man yeah he is
a notebook he's incredible oh dude he's
like a swiss army notebook yeah he um
but i mean is there an option like to be
like after like an hour of like tapping
out or like you're just stuck i think
you want to but i think part of the
mystique about joe rogans is that you go
in there and you're like
you know i want to be able to go
toe-to-toe you know what i'm saying he's
kind of like this um this symbol of of
not necessarily just machismo but
somewhat of machismo for sure yeah so
you want to be able to be like okay i
can do my time you know it's like i hung
in there with him yes yeah and it's
you're just like dude and you hit about
two hours and you have a cramp that
you're trying to deny and you're still
trying to like get your bathroom yeah oh
totally he'll do a bathroom break
sometimes
um
i remember at one point i remember
saying hey man this is the longest
conversation i've ever been in my entire
life for sure
and it was and it was like almost scary
to think that you know that i'm talking
to a man that that uh
that i've gotten to know better but i
didn't know super great at the time
that was scary man i feel like it's a
it's going in there it's kind of scary
because then they close the door and the
sound kind of gets whoo
that's just you guys
and you almost think he can hear like
you like the internet's in your head yet
he's just like peering through your
brain like he's got that third ear yeah
bro some people got that third eye
sometimes i feel like joe has that third
ear man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one